at Leonardo DiCaprio you were one of the
first people to work with him I was even
in this American boys it's always like
well maybe was about 14 or 13 or 14
young must be amazing to see you know to
watch his career yes yeah yeah Leo was
also we had a reading of the movie and
Leo wasn't reading the lead it was
another kid and and at the end of it I
said this kid is interesting you know
you should you know pay more attention
to him
and I don't know whether that my saying
that had anything to do with it you know
it did anointed by proper to the hero
other kids who knows where they are now
someone else though someone else had a
huge influence on Leonardo DiCaprio's
career I turned to Paul Rudd though you
probably don't know I don't think I had
an influence but I sometimes I you know
looking back you find yourself at some
interesting conversations and moments in
time and I worked with Leonardo on Romeo
and Juliet and at the time my father
made his living he was a Titanic expert
and he used to take people all over the
world talking about Titanic he couldn't
go to universities and yeah and it was
my last day of filming on Romeo and
Juliet and we all went out to a bar
afterward all the guys we were all a
bunch of guys working on the movie and
so we were in different cars and I was
riding to the place with Leo and he said
I just got offered this movie and it's a
big movie he had done indie films to
that point he said it's a big it's a
studio movie it's a Titanic and I said
that's incredible and I knew a lot about
Titanic because my dad just talking
about
and we just had a conversation about it
and he was saying I'm like I don't know
what I'll do
I remember saying you should do it don't
think I had any say but it is kind of
interesting to think back on that yeah
there was a moment when he might have
done yeah cuz he did it he didn't do the
movie
[Applause]
[Music]
you